so yeah nothing nothing by the way gives
me more pleasure than like to provide
for my wife that like it's so
um fun because man I I went to the
airport this morning and I'm stupid I
forgot my passport I called my wife
she's like did you forget password like
yes they did she's like I'll be right
there she literally dropped everything
like got whichever kid was at home in
the car and drove straight to the
airport and I and I as I said it's our
10 year wedding anniversary and I said
I'm so glad you know if I wasn't married
to for these last 10 years I would be
missing a fight right now
but you know but there are so many
there's so many little things that
she'll do to like actually make my life
easier because she's because she's
actually beautiful but it wasn't but it
wasn't because like it just she figured
out that like because she loves you as
well well well of course I hope I mean I
would I would hope she loves you and she
knows that you love her but you know
it's like I would love to find somebody
to fund my retirement well actually
let's just say that's true of course you
would of course he would who wouldn't
want that right but it's like are you
the person like are you a person some of
that guy picks and that's that's a
question we talk about this in business
it's like you see a prospect he doesn't
buy it's like our like that Prospect is
going to buy that product somewhere at
some point but are you are you being the
person that that Prospect wants to buy
from
you know and so it shifts the
responsibility on me to better my and so
I'll tell you guys that's sorry I was 20
I was 22 I was 22 years old I was
sitting down with a mentor of mine who
had like a massive impact on my life he
was about 40 years old like extremely
successful with women with finances
everything the guy was just the stud
went on to become a VP of a public
company that sold for like a billion
dollars just crazy private companies so
[__] those are crazy
and I asked them and I was really really
frustrated I was 22 years old I hadn't
got laid in about a year
[Music]
I was 22 and been late in about a year
wow that was a bad choice
um because because look look I didn't
kiss the girls until I was 20 that's why
because I I needed to I didn't
understand the reality of what I was
dealing with I had delusions in my mind
like I thought I would meet a girl 20
and marry her because my grandparents
were both married until everybody died
all both sets of grandparents to meet
you oh she's something yeah like
what's your thoughts obviously you're a
married man and I've always wanted to
ask amandis
obviously of your level and it's like
what do you think about
um what's it called again prenup yeah
what do you think about that did you go
against the marriages of this girl man I
have a really I have some really
controversial opinions on this and if
you'd like me to shout out share
um
I had two conditions uh three conditions
for for getting married
the first condition was my wife has to
take my last name
it wasn't a religious Choice it was that
a mentor of mine told me that it
signified something my mom didn't take
my dad's last name and they got divorced
and I saw that my mom didn't respect my
dad like I felt he deserved the respect
even though he suffered he suffered with
dignity that was number one
uh number two no prenup
that was a decision I made principally I
made that decision no prenup like I told
my wife like I didn't know if I was ever
gonna get married but if I went for it I
was gonna go all in but I'm gonna make a
real strategic decision I'm gonna go all
freaking in that's the way it should be
that that was the way that was love that
was my choice and I admit it might not
be the most because people are gonna say
oh but you're a businessman you're
making a discount you know not a risk
mitigating decision I made a choice but
you know I'll tell you something my
wife's told me this many many times like
sort of in a playful way kind of talk
you know because we have hard
conversations sometimes she's like look
if you divorce me I don't want any money
I just she just said I just want to make
sure that I have the kids and I said and
that's great that's what I want too
right
um but but that's but I made that
decision I made that decision to step
into that and say I'm gonna risk
everything because maybe it's a
courageous you know delusion that I had
at the time and maybe I'm just lucky
that it worked out the way it has so far
so would you say that there's no room or
right when it comes to that kind of
decision I was it down to you as an
individual because it is like a business
is kind of marriage marriage to marriage
to me was uh look again 85 percent is it
are the laws different in the country
you're in are they I'm not compared in
Canada first oh okay so that's something
that is a terrible place to do it right
okay really
um why well because the Canadian court
system just is like Australia or the US
it just really favors women
but but you know what but I felt like I
vouched my wife's character you know
what's crazy my wife's never had a
public Instagram I'll just tell you
right now she never had it by the way
people that meet my wife they're like
wow Dimitri like really like they're
impressed that I got a girl of that
caliber because she's you know five ton
blonde don't nod your head are you
better no not cool you know my wife's
like like I have a type and it's her
like 5 10 blonde like you know people
say wow is she like a model or something
because you know so I did well in that
regard but I vouched her I like vetted
her character so like no public
Instagram I'm gonna say this no tattoos
no piercings okay hate me I don't care
no tattoos no piercings no public
Instagram great relationship with her
dad her dad's a heart surgeon like
incredible like successful Stern man
great relationship one of three sisters
she's the oldest of three uh educated uh
could have a lot of dudes chose not to
uh and in fact I was my wife and I have
my wife's first and only serious
relationship
wow so I guess if you choose right
you don't need the degrees for life well
and of course like what bigger decision
can a man make than to get married like
everything right I I I I I kind of hear
what he's saying I think when you're
looking for a partner
you need to actually look at do they
actually Little Things
does it match with the person and if
they're little things match and if you
can deal with one another's differences
in opinions I think that's that's a
winner because then you're showing that
you have respect in your listening and
you're working as a team how a
relationship should be I have a question
sorry go ahead go ahead I was gonna pick
so I'm sitting with my mentor I'm 22
years old I remembered very vividly like
I I got to the party late you know what
I mean like I didn't kiss a girl until I
was 20.
um and then like I'm 22 and I'm single
and I'm frustrated and my life is not
going the way I wanted to go and I'm
like why am I like why by the way by 23
a lot of things I bought my first house
at 23 and I was a full-time University
student so like there was a lot of
changes that I was undergoing like I
started going to the gym I started doing
things that sucked like I took cold
showers every freaking morning in fact
my 1988 Toyota Corolla actual 1988
Toyota Corolla that I took a girl on a
date on told me that she'll never go on
a date with me again because my car
smells like old people and she thought I
was a psycho which makes sense because
my Corolla had a Ferrari sticker on the
steering wheel Tony Robbins no it was
Napoleon Hill secrets of whatever
Napoleon Hill playing and motivational
quotes posted on all the mirrors so I
look like a crazy person right okay so
anyways 22. I'm sitting with a mentor of
mine I'm like and I said dude like how
do I get a happy and successful
girlfriend I want a girlfriend you've
done the Mandarin for the girlfriend
well I just that's who I was at 22. yeah
I I went through the other phase too by
the way like like
I went through that and if you're
listening to Napoleon Hill at 22 wow but
obviously because well guys
because I lived in the actual projects
well done like I lived like you know the
projects are social housing I introduced
you to him
um literally I was rollerblading and
somebody's like recruited me to go into
sales like hey you look really motivated
come to sales and I'm like oh they think
I'm motivated I'm just poor I'm just
poor but here's the and by the way like
so so he I said how do I get a happy and
successful girlfriend at the time I was
just I just wanted a girl to like me I
wasn't thinking about like anything else
yeah of course he goes he goes oh that's
easy you just have to be happy and
successful yeah and I thought about that
a lot and it comes back to you know
McConaughey quote he does the thing like
don't chase the butterfly build a garden
the butterflies will come so a mentor of
mine
a huge impact on my life like he really
told me like he's like just build your
own value focus on you and do everything
you need to do to be the most attractive
guy to the to women around you because I
wasn't an attractive guy to women around
me I was rollerblading to University in
the 1988 Corolla was falling apart the
driving test I took the first time he
didn't let me drive the cars did they
borrow my dad's car because he said the
car does not look safe
so you know at 22 I'm not a good
Prospect for women so like now my mind
changed like oh it's not that I'm not
good at getting women is that women
don't want me why not well because I'm
22 and I was a at the time I was going
to University I was professionally
gaming I was playing games 14 15 hours a
day I stunk so Dimitri why do you think
you were able to take that feedback
where most women if you say the men you
want don't want you because because the
pain of staying the same was greater
than the pain of change it just hurt too
freaking much to be fair at 22 men are
at that level where they're not
um they're not as highly you know I'm
talking from a perspective a 22 year old
man and a 20 year old woman yeah yeah a
22 year old role a 22 year old woman is
a lot more desired than a 22 year old
man at that stage but we could use the
opposite like a 42 year old man and a 42
year old woman yeah the man's gonna be a
lot more desired than the woman
definitely because now he's in his game
it actually it switches for women about
30 um according to eating ABS yeah yeah
where it's all facts it's like where the
tables turn well and there's and there's
a wisdom there too like Why Did I Get
Married I'll say why I have friends that
are 40 that are very successful they
never got married right
um
I kind of looked at it like I understand
obviously that men's value grows with
time and women's value like this
whatever you call sexual market value
goes down yeah yeah
but but that's like what actually in my
opinion my this is an opinion in my
opinion that's what makes a successful
man a man who can be dangerous but
chooses not to be and chooses to control
it that to me is like a really high
aspiration for a way of living and that
might be wrong but but I love that I
love the aspiration of being able to do
the things that are dangerous but
choosing to control that danger so I I
have a question with the prenup stuff I
feel like it's tough because it's almost
like if you have a kid you're screwed
anyway yeah when it comes to marriage
like just I've been doing this
documentary on the court system but even
so I just don't think I could ever
advise a guy not to get a prenup because
um because just the outcomes are so
catastrophic especially when I'm
learning like about
um men like committing suicide a lot
during that it's like a really big
problem and I started um asking Uber
drivers that I drive with and I'll just
start asking them questions and I found
out like I would guess like one out of
four of my Uber drivers they somehow
were in the court system
in some way so it's like all these men
that were just financially ruined and
they're 40 to their 50s to the point
they're never going to come back so do
you advise men to like do the same route
that you did because I would just have a
hard time doing that my you know I'm a
logical guy and I like to think of like
in things about mitigating risk probably
I made a very sub-optimal decision
um I'm very happy with my decision there
was a personal choice for me to you know
I I get really hard for commitment I get
hard for discipline it's just how it
commitment turns me on I've done one
thing in my life you know at a
university selling door-to-door I
started a company that's I sold suits
the door to door in Office Buildings
which has just grown to 20 countries we
now have over 100 people working at our
company I've only that's the only thing
I've done I don't like jumping around I
don't like to I don't like to look for
success in places that I don't know they
exist I don't like to
I don't like to look at my neighbor's
lawn I like to fertilize my own lawn so
for me that decision of commitment was
actually bigger than the risk that I
felt and that's just me not everybody's
gonna feel that way and um and that's
okay I mean I don't think I don't know
if there's a right answer I think this
is to me it's just first I was just
wondering you so many guys you Mentor so
I was just curious if you advise them
the same way I tell my guys this never
marry from a weak position never commit
from a weak position what I mean from a
weak position you know when you see red
flags and you're like everybody's you
know everybody knows that you see the
red flags and you choose to ignore them
why because that's the only option you
have and like I tell guys in our company
when they joined they're in their early
20s I'm like don't like
don't commit to the first girl you
freaking kiss man because you're like
there's things you're not gonna see like
go and run the hose just straight up I
go go through the 304s run it run it run
it run it so that sorry man that's
that's a very different I expect you to
have more of a trap that's very opposite
no no that is that is the optimum the op
the optimal thing that a man can do is
make himself as highly attractive to
women as possible as possible to
increase his pool and then pick the
option that optimizes for him and then
commit to that now some people might say
oh you should have three or four wives
some people want that I don't want that
like I'm I'm happy what did you think
about what he said earlier about guys
liking
um Alpha women sometimes like certain
guys well I found myself very my mom is
an alpha woman she's a high high income
earner
um compared to my dad so she actually
her career took off you know in computer
science she's got a master's computer
science so when we moved to Canada she
was like the Soviet engineer and her
career took off and my dad just remained
a humble mechanic
um and so I found myself at a young age
attracted to these women that were sort
of like argumentative uh sometimes would
cause a scene in public because that's
my mom
um and and wanted control and I made a
and again I I started finding myself
attracted to those women and I remember
my first serious girlfriend for two
years she never cooked a meal she said I
think it's beneath women to cook for men
in the bin it was and that wasn't the
only and that was the only that wasn't
the only thing can I share something
something that came in my mind basically
what you're saying is I get it because
you know for example a lot of people DM
me saying they talk about my chest and
that and I'm like is it because they've
got a fat mom and they've been like you
know when they're breastfeeding so
that's why they DM me talking about
wanting to lick my nipples and all that
so I get it it comes from childhood and
it comes from like little things like
you know what I mean
it comes from certain feelings must come
from childhood for them to have those
things as adults and I really believe
people that have fat mothers also like
fat people uh there is the studies
there's a study that's been shown that
poor men prefer uh corpulent you know
larger women and what's interesting
about that I'm like I'm like I wonder if
it's a sign of well I know I I wonder if
it's because that's just the pool that
they have available to them you know and
obviously if you grow poor there's more
likelihood you will be poor like of
course there is that like we know that
wow
um
yeah sorry you were gonna no I was just
gonna actually like in terms obviously
every man's different yeah you see me I
couldn't be of a girl for two years one
year six months no food you can't cook
no did not are you mad what's going on
what um
you're probably just naturally better
with women than I was I wasn't naturally
good at it but but you know what I did
no I'm just serious like if you worked
where you worked and you were getting
something I'd like to know you got good
riddles I don't want to like maybe I
argue and I'm being too you know we're
talking about being picky some men don't
care about cooking they'll teach you I
know how to cook so I do care very much
and my wife cooks all the time and it's
amazing and it's only steak at our house
now that's the rule this month I have
only eaten steak at home this month the
only thing anyways
um I I was intentional about again I'll
just share my thing this everybody's
different I had a book uh a vision book
I believed in actualization because my
mentor said you need to believe in it
okay I said fine I don't believe in
astrology but I'll try this stuff
whatever I had a book and one of the it
was like a folder there was like you
know go in different areas and one of
the uh one of the dividers was about my
ideal mate and I actually described very
vividly with pictures what my ideal mate
would be to me that included not only
looks of course looks was there it was
number one uh for me it also included
you know background family really like I
got really detailed I had another Mentor
who was 39 he sold this company at 39
for 50 million bucks and just look a guy
put me on the board of his freaking
company just he I said dude I was like
24 I'm like what are you doing he goes
Dimitri I want you to just sit there and
listen We're not gonna pay you I just
want you to sit and listen so you can be
around these people and just see how
they talk see how they think and just
learn from them and I learned a ton from
that right and and he was like girl's
relationship with her father matters a
lot I didn't know why I didn't
understand it but I said okay so I wrote
down I want my future wife to have an
amazing relationship with her dad and
respect her father this was the words he
said respect her father so I I got
really really detailed right now as I
got into like 24 25 26 my options opened
up profusely like it was like it was
like good times at that time but then I
was choosing from the women that made
themselves available to me and I and I
didn't turn the sex down let's put it
that way but in terms of like who I was
gonna wife up I knew exactly what I
wanted and that may be different from
different people but I really want to
take a strategic position and I was
willing to wait you know I was willing
to wait because the sex was available
you know I think I think if the guys
aren't getting laid then they're
probably just gonna yes get married for
the P that's a terrible decision I got
married for the character and I I you
know and that and that's been the intent
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible